[Musique]
donc on a un problème vous savez c'est
une obligation légale en fait d'aller à
la police contenant un cadavre sur les
bras des séquelles la place dans la
prochaine on n'a qu'à la mettre là
dedans en attendant tu sais valentine
dommage que ta cousine et pas été à
l'académie française quand même pourquoi
tu me disent ah bah parce qu'elle serait
devenue immortelle et mesa ba hy dans
l'espace que les académiciens alors su
renoncer des immortels c'est une blague
ceva la cousine de alors qu'il n'est pas
utile mortel est morte c'est pas drôle
non mais c'est vrai que je suis pas allé
de main morte non mais arrête mais non
mais vous avez raison
désolé valentine avec 60 ans mort dans
ma référence à raison en plus c'est les
gens n'ont pas vu les autres épisodes et
m'ont rien comprendre
mort de rire
[Musique]
en premier épisode de cette saison
valentine vous a parlé de rire et de ses
caractéristiques générales ou universel
pourtant il ya une réponse à laquelle
elle n'a pas répondu et qui moi me
travaille un peu
peut-on rire de tout normalement à la
simple évocation de cette phrase vous
pensez à des proches vous me répondez
que oui mais pas avec tout le monde et
vous êtes déjà en train de bouchard pied
dans les commentaires ou sur twitter
parce que du temps de coluche on était
libres alors que maintenant avec le
politiquement correct et à cause de ces
cônes à la question est intéressante
mais lorsque l'on y répond c'est
toujours sur le même aspect moi ça
m'ennuie parce qu'il en a un qu'on
explore jamais et qui à moi me paraît
évident l'humour est il lié à la culture
ou à la langue
après tout peut-être bien qu'on peut pas
rire de tout avec tout le monde tout
simplement parce qu'en ayant des langues
maternelles différentes des cultures
différentes ne peut pas être tous
réceptifs aux mêmes vannes vous avez
forcément entendu parler d'humour
anglais on vous êtes peut-être déjà
surpris à penser que les allemands
n'avaient pas d'humour
et pour les plus téméraires vous savez
peut-être même tenté une sitcom bruce
qui vous a laissé perplexe dès
l'antiquité on s'était penché sur la
question cicéron distinguer deux types
d'humour à savoir le d'airé et le dedic
tôt soit littéralement le rire les
choses et le rire du 10 cette
distinction la fais toujours mon la
nomme avec des concepts différents
on parle désormais plus tôt d'humour
référentiel d'un côté et d'humour verbal
de l'autre mais mou référentiel celui
qui se bat sur le contexte
essentiellement et ne dépend pas de
composantes linguistiques tandis que
l'humour verbal lui en dépend
directement sérieux t'a parlé de cicéron
là non oui c'est que cicéron si poincaré
non c'est drôle parce qu'en fait il ya
carré dedans et ils peuvent caresser un
mec il a fait des trucs dans l'histoire
de france
c'est beaucoup trop long il est né à bar
le duc c'est beaucoup trop triste en
plus de ça pour la blague de valentine
est terrible de médiocrité on est
d'accord il n'en reste pas moins qu'elle
se base sur des éléments strictement
linguistique à savoir la prononciation
en français de deux noms et de leurs
homophonie avec d'autres mots de la
langue
cicéron cicéron vous énoncez se
transcrit strictement identiques mans en
écriture phonétique et c'est là tout ce
qu'ils ont en commun c'est clairement
dedic tôt c'est de l'humour verbal ma
réaction c'est vous a fait sourire
relève en revanche du der et de l'humour
référentiel parce que ben le mec est né
à bar-le-duc et je crois que j'ai pas
tant besoin d'expliquer pourquoi c'est
drôle parce que bar-le-duc quoi
vous avez déjà été à bar le duc vous
avez dit j'étais dans la meuse
fatalement l'humour verbal est dépendant
de la langue sur laquelle ils se basent
si je tente de l'humour verbale dans une
autre langue une langue que vous ne
parlez pas je serai bien emmerdé pour
vous expliquer en quoi c'est censé vous
arracher un sourire si je dois en venir
aux explications aux n'aura de toute
façon troqué la galéjade par un moment
de malaise
voilà comme celui là bref par essence
l'humour qui se base sur un longue
exclut de fait ceux qui ne la parle pas
dans ce cas précis il est légitime de
dire qu'on peut rire de tout mais pas
avec tout le monde et valentin où aller
ce black and white and roll over you
j'ai pas compris
mais si j'appliquais weitz et des
couleurs tracé noir et blanc est raide
ça veut dire roule mais ça veut dire lui
parce que c'est un journal c'est un jeu
de mots oui voilà c'est marrant je parle
pas super bien roulé au fait qu'est ce
donc toi tu es gens et scientifique mais
tu parle pas anglais trop bien moi j'ai
envie d'applaudir
venez applaudir valentine traduire ce
genre de blagues et bien souvent
impossible comme l'humour verbal peut
aussi tirer profit d'une situation
donnée ou rebondir sur des mots qui ont
pu être dit quelques phrases auparavant
les traducteurs de sitcom américaine
s'arrachent les cheveux pour restituer
au mieux non pas le texte original mais
la réaction que ce texte est censé
susciter parce qu'une bonne traduction
n'est pas forcément littérale et même
surtout pas dans le cadre du mans
verbale et si beaucoup préfèrent
l'original à la bf et part je suis
désolé mais des fois la vf est très bien
le taf mêmes surpasse la vo j'invoque ce
parc comme exemple est ce que tu vas là
des glaciers cette poche un poil on va
se faire dégommer en commentaire hein je
vous préviens parfois il faut accepter
que l'on ne puisse tout simplement pas
restituer cet humour dans une autre
langue parce qu'ils dépendent trop du
contexte culturel parce qu'il est trop
ancrée dans un univers linguistique
parce qu'ils exploitent des codes trop
spécifique et non transposable à
l'étranger c'est le cas de camelot par
exemple l'un des programmes les plus
cultes et des plus drôles des années
2000 pour beaucoup de francophones mais
qui n'a pas su trouver son public à
l'étranger dans d'autres langues
je ne donne pas cet exemple au hasard il
ya quelques temps je suis tombé sur un
article de zine des pannes qui m'a pas
mal marqué une journaliste ayant grandi
en france il parlait de sa difficulté à
faire comprendre à son mari américain
pourquoi cette série-là faisait rire il
se trouve que camelot exploite
énormément le détournement de colocation
ou de locutions figé les colocations
sont des termes qui fonctionne souvent
ensemble dans la langue comme
un crochus courir vite voix grave casser
les noix lorsque ces termes ne peuvent
plus fonctionner indépendamment l'un de
l'autre sans trahir le sens général de
l'expression on parle alors de locutions
figé comme pomme de terre
hôtel de ville le dindon de la farce
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais compris moi cette
histoire de dindons et de farce la jeu
faudra qu'on m'explique dans le langage
courant les gens parlent souvent
d'expression ou même d'expressions
toutes faites et d'ailleurs expressions
toutes faites et bien c'est une
expression toute faite et ça c'est
marrant pour résumer le détournement de
colocation de locutions figé c'est quand
on prend une expression français est ce
que l'on y substituer des mots par
d'autres vos proches ou qui en tout cas
permettre de préserver le sens global et
ce afin de créer un décalage ne dit pas
en plein dans sa gueule mais en plein
dans samui ne dit pas je voudrais pas
faire mon relou mais je voudrais pas
faire ma raquette et vous obtenez le
principal ressort comique de camelot
tout le personnage de perceval est
construit sur ce modèle d'ailleurs plus
généralement une partie de l'humour de
la série repose sur les registres de
langue le registre c'est la façon de
vous exprimer en fonction d'une
situation sociale particulière cela
concerne aussi bien le choix des mots la
construction de la phrase où
l'intonation que vous allez prendre
c'est un peu comme les habits on se
fringue pas pareil pour un entretien
d'embauché dans un cabinet d'avocats que
pour ben la soirée pizza du denis quoi
et les registres sont rarement mélanger
sauf lorsque l'on cherche à créer un
décalage exemple mais vous n'êtes pas
morts espèce de connard ou encore si je
vous dis que vous êtes de gland là vous
avez dû péremptoire ici le vouvoiement
et le lexique soutenu qui donne un côté
anciens viennent trancher que la
vulgarité populaire de termes très
actuel le film les visiteurs utilisaient
les mêmes ressorts comiques quelques
années auparavant d'ailleurs si l'on
regarde par exemple la version espagnole
du film on se rend compte que souvent
les références linguistiques et l'humour
lie au registre n'a pas pu être
conservés des tournures volontairement
fautive ou ambigu dans la version
française ont été corrigée dans la
version espagnole par exemple et cela
explique peut-être pourquoi le film a
d'ailleurs eu une étoile de moins sur
film affinity españa que sur allociné
que ce soit dans kaamelott ou dans les
visiteurs ce ressort comique
linguistique fonctionne extrêmement bien
en français parce que seul à exploiter
particularité grammaticales et un
contexte culturel particulier et qu'on
ne retrouve pas vraiment en espagne en
angleterre aux etats unis
de toute façon les registres populaire
aux familiers sont difficiles à traduire
ou adapté parce qu'ils contiennent une
information objective en plus d'une
information sociale
ils sont le fruit d'évolution
linguistique laisser dans les mains de
l'usaj tout ça pour dire difficile de
faire comprendre aux anglo saxons
pourquoi pas changer assiette pour
fromage est à mourir de rire
ou à pour coup hier ou ce genre de
choses en fait tu vois une même marque
d'un pays à l'autre pas forcément
communiquer avec de l'humour en fait
déjà dans le cas d'une grosse marque
multinationales et cetera tu va
forcément avoir un siège social dans un
peu tous les pays et en plus à
département marketing dans ce pays qui
va être lié à une agence de com
spécifiques à ce pays là et ça c'est
super important parce que forcément tu
vas pas communiqué la même façon parce
que t'as pas forcément les mêmes
concurrents dans un pays n'a pas
forcément la même cible visée tu peux ce
que pour x ou y raison et du coup tu as
surtout pas les mêmes moeurs la même
culture et donc pas la même manière de
s'adresser aux gens et pas les mêmes
objectifs aussi pour la marque parce que
une même marque dans un pays peut être
leader et pas du tout c'est un autre
genre de choses alors après évidemment
tu as quand même des des grosses
campagnes internationales qui ont tourné
dans plein de pays à grosse échelle et
qui vont juste en fait être récupéré et
traduit localement par ces gens au zoo
comme membres vont se dire ok on a du
visuel on a des chouettes extraits vidéo
maintenant on va redoubler par dessus
par exemple pour ça d'ailleurs que tu as
parfois des pubs qui sont un peu double
et un peu dégueulasse comme ça avec 105
ronnie bout des lèvres agents des trucs
mais enfin mon chéri ce sont trois
choses en même temps tu sais et dans le
cas de l'humour c'est vachement
compliqué parce que
si tu as du jeu de mots c'est vraiment
ce qui est plus le plus difficile à
adapter
c'était vraiment une marque qui dit ok
on va communiquer dans tous les pays que
des trucs à base de jeux de mots c'est
pratiquement impossible et ce cas là bas
ça nous a paru même au sein d'un même
pays parce que par exemple en belgique
n'importe quelle campagne de com elle
doit être traduite en français et en
néerlandais donc bah forcément tu évites
le jeunot parce que ou alors tout à le
penser en amont alors disant ok on a un
bon jeu de man française qu'on a eu
aussi bien en néerlandais
ce que ça veut dire la même chose est-ce
que ça transmettre mon truc et sert à
quoi donc voilà donc l'humour dans le
cadre de la com
en tout cas est clairement culturel mais
si on ne peut pas traduire efficacement
l'humour vers bali le restituer peut-on
au moins la prendre peut-on apprendre
l'humour verbal si apprendre une langue
peut déjà vous paraît difficile je suis
désolé de vous dire que la maîtrise de
jeunots est un exercice bien plus dur
encore maîtrisé l'humour verbal cela
demande de maîtriser la langue dans
laquelle celui ci prend place de très
bien la maîtriser mais pour cela il ne
faut pas être en insécurité linguistique
c'est à dire qu'il ne peut pas ressentir
de malaise lorsque l'on parle il a peur
de faire une erreur
au contraire il faut être extrêmement
confiant dans son niveau et dans sa
capacité à être compris et rien que ça
c'est un gros morceau parce que lorsque
l'on parle une langue étrangère c'est
rarement le cas par ailleurs si vous
tentez de faire un jeu de mots dans une
langue qui n'est pas votre langue
maternelle on aura peut-être tendance à
partir du principe que vous avez
confondu de termes ou que vous avez
mélanger deux expressions que cela n'est
pas intentionnel en tant que natif
sachez que vous subirez une présentation
la faute aux yeux des autres des natifs
vous n'aurez pas fait un trait d'humour
où vous serez trompé et c'est ça qui
leur sera drôle les attendront de vous
que vous utilisez la bonne prononciation
la bonne intonation l'utilisation des
registres populaire ou familiers vous
fera passer pour un amateur
peut-être faudra-t-il alors insisté
expliquer votre trait d'humour ce qui en
soi n'est jamais aux petits malins quand
on veut juste faire sourire les gens
ce simple fait peut déjà vous en
dissuader
si vous trouvez ce présupposé raciste ou
ethnocentrée de la part de vos amis ou
de votre auditoire
si vous trouvez que cela met à mal votre
intégration dans une autre communauté
linguistique je ne vous contredirai pas
en revanche c'est assez facilement
explicable renversons la balance en
mandarin beaucoup de mots ne se
distingue que par les tons c'est à dire
que beaucoup de mots sont identiques en
tous points si ce n'est dans
l'intonation avec laquelle ils sont
prononcés nous européens avons beaucoup
de mal avec cela nous francophones tout
particulièrement
imaginez que vous vouliez parler du
cheval de l'herbe et de la boue a même
répandu sur l'internet chinois qui se
dit çà on him as qu à la place vous dit
ça
nima c'est-à-dire niktamère s'anime à
saran ni s'anime à bord il est probable
que je viens de dire nique ta mère en
mandarin sur youtube la hausse a pas ce
malaise malaise même si vous l'avez fait
exprès même si vous avez voulu être
drôle comme moi en écrivant ce script
coup dur coup dur l'humour verbal en
mandarin exploite beaucoup cette
caractéristique linguistique il se
trouve que le premier terme sur ceux
désignés une espèce d'alpaga et qui fut
à l'origine d'un véritable phénomène
culturel en chine est un jeu de mot
justement tiré du second terme qui est
une insulte comme il se trouve que nous
autres européens avons tendance à ne
jamais bien prononcé ni l'un ni l'autre
il est légitime pour les chinois de
croire qu en fonction du contexte nous
parlons de l'un ou de l'autre et que
nous nous trompions souvent sans faire
exprès que selon eux nous voulons
simplement dire l'autre phrase celle qui
leur paraît la bonne j'imagine que dans
beaucoup de cas cela nous sauf plus que
le contraire
croyez moi j'ai connu ce genre de
situation quand je vivais en autriche
hélas ce moment je voulais écrire une
petite saynète là et tout mais vous
alliez rien comprendre
parce que c'est en allemand et que c'est
intraduisible parce que ben tout ce
qu'on vient de déjà dire dans l'épisode
et j'aime terrain sinon on va encore
dire que les bilingues isla raconte trop
de toute façon même en cas de maîtrise
parfaite de la langue
il en reste une qui reste déterminant
pour saisir et faire de l'humour en
langue étrangère maîtrisez-vous le
contexte culturel se trouve qu'à l'école
on apprend avant tout les langues
vivantes sous un aspect fonctionnel et
utilitaires et si on apprend parfois un
peu de culture que les anglais ont des
bus rouge avec les allemands mangent les
saucisses par exemple bas ce n'est
jamais au centre de l'enseignement alors
on pourrait débattre pour savoir si
c'est bien si c'est mal mais toujours
est il qu'on ait toute façon limité par
le temps scolaire et qu'on est en dehors
de l'immersion linguistique qui serait
nécessaire bah ouais c'est pas une heure
de cours de langue avec un prof qui vont
remplacer la vie au pays surtout si on
est trente élèves francophones
monolingues
provost collège à bar-le-duc et sans
avoir accès aux références culturelles
sans connaître les petites phrases
drôles qui rident telle série de tels
films difficile de saisir l'humour d'une
situation est encore plus dur de le
reproduire sans que ça tape à côté et
donc sans passer pour un blaireau quoi
évidemment aujourd'hui l'impérialisme
linguistique de l'anglais conduit un
lissage des références culturelles en
imposant l'humour qui lui est liée à
tous les pays sous influence anglo
saxonne comme un socle commun fin sauf à
bar-le-duc l'objet d'un poster de ouf la
bac la surexposition la langue anglaise
nous conduit en adopté également les
codes c'est vrai en occident en tout cas
parce que pour autant l'humour en
extrême orient reste particulièrement
différent dans notre sphère culturelle
recentrer être drôle et quelque chose de
positif et c'est même un trait de
personnalité qui nous rend plus désir a
plus motivant plus capable et plus
créatifs aux yeux des autres en chine
par contre le confucianisme a joué un
rôle important
l'humour est moins bien perçu et être
drôle et pas considéré comme attrait des
personnalités souhaitable ni comme une
source de créativité d'ailleurs et c'est
plutôt considéré comme une faculté
réservé à certaines personnes expertes
de l'exercice cela va même plus loin le
type d'humour utilisé ou le but que ses
recettes humour dépend de votre culture
par exemple le fait de réduire le stress
bien l'humour est un très très
occidentale et si vous tentez d'utiliser
ce moyen dans le milieu professionnel en
chine
cela risque de mal passer d'ailleurs
même chez les enfants les chinois ont
tendance à percevoir l'humour comme un
signe d'agression pouvant mettre en
péril la cohésion de groupe
contrairement aux enfants canadiens par
exemple de culture européenne qui eux le
perçoivent positivement au delà de votre
bonne maîtrise linguistique donc sans
maîtriser les arcanes culturels du
milieu où vous évoluez votre humour peut
totalement être déplacés d'ailleurs
plusieurs pays partagent la même langue
sans que la culture soit totalement
identique
un film de comédie espagnole ne fait pas
forcément rire en amérique du sud une
sitcom américaine ne fait pas forcément
rire en écosse on parlait de la
traduction des oeuvres humoristique tout
à l'heure on pourrait également parler
des remake qui ne sont pas forcément une
mauvaise idée
même au sein du même espace linguistique
vous connaissez sûrement caméra café par
exemple la série diffusée de 2001 à 2004
sur m6 et bien sachez qu'elle a été
adapté au québec est diffusée de 2002 à
2012 soit pendant dix ans le succès de
la version outre atlantique est sans
aucun doute due à l'adaptation qui
avaient toutes les possibilités
d'exploiter les références culturelles
locales
bref l'humour verbal peut donc
théoriquement s'apprendre si vous
comptiez faire une carrière d'humoriste
aux états unis et loire votre one man
show en anglais finir sur les filles si
deux ans autant vous dire que vous
partez de loin et
pas mal de handicap surtout si l'on part
de bar le duc dont je t'ai marrante et
tu manges bien t'es mort alors tu manges
tellement vrai jeu tendre non mais monte
on a déjà parlé tu peux pas dire mange
tes morts et surtout pas à quelqu'un qui
vient de perdre un proche
c'était pour rire mais c'est pas drôle
en plus times est sûre ça quand même
fait rire à eau de cuisson son ordi perd
quelqu'un de sa famille à la prochaine
fois je dirais
et dès la de la jetée mort en suédois
mais celui-là c'est un peuple sans fin
ils mangent du rennes mais s'en sortir
d'europe
même sans quitter la france le contexte
culturel peut vraiment vous mettre en
difficulté pour comprendre l'humour
parce que si la langue est une barrière
nette et si les cultures étrangères
représentent aussi des ensembles assez
bien conceptualise abl la culture en
france n'est pas uniforme
un notaire de paris n'aura pas les mêmes
références culturelles qui est un
ouvrier de bar-le-duc par exemple ou de
vierzon pour changer ou de valenciennes
et références levett diverses
transcender les classes sociales ou non
être régionalisées ou non l'humour sert
alors aussi au sein d'une même
communauté linguistique à se positionner
socialement c'est quelque chose qui ne
leur pas monolithique ni uniforme au
sein des pays ou des cultures dont nous
avons parlé ce qui rajoute évidemment
une autre couche de complexité
si cet épisode vous a plu si vous avez
et riz ou pas et ben n'hésitez pas à
aller sur discorde pour en parler
évidemment le lien est en description
vous pouvez vous abonner mettre la
cloche laïque et commentés partager et
voilà
façon je suis sûr si valentina les pas
sensiblement humour ce parce que c'est
une bourgeoise qui viennent je sais pas
quelle grande du genre bordeaux non ça
c'est parce que tu est désagréable c'est
bon ya pas mort d'homme
alors si justement en fait trois morts
deux femmes déjà ok moi ce que je veux
c'est qu'on arrête de rigoler de sages
on arrête de faire des blagues là-dessus
genre vraiment en ses chiens ouais c'est
lourd
eh bien ça lui oui c'est moi c'est moi
chez moi c'est moi chez moi depuis
twitch c'est moi sur twitter
actuellement et comme c'était annoncé
sur instagram d'ailleurs donc si jamais
vous voulez discuter de ce sujet ce
sujet vous a plu qui ce sujet vous a
intéressé
sachez que vous pouvez tout à fait venir
en débattre vous venir dire ce que vous
en avez pensé et tutti quanti finalement
est sûre ce et bien bonne soirée à vous